now for rise and shine you know you've
you co-wrote co-produced this entire
thing this is the first time that you
had a hand in writing like
every song is that correct yeah i sort
of didn't feel comfortable taking
outside songs for this
project because i feel like it's just
too personal and too intimate with it
being acoustic
to saying something that i didn't write
[Music]
what was the genesis the idea behind
this whole cp
well it was really at the beginning of
the quarantine not
at the very beginning but probably like
three weeks in where i
was like i feel like i'm supposed to be
doing something and i know that's
probably a lot to do with the fact that
i'm usually
touring and busy but i just felt like i
felt something tugging at me like i
needed to do
something meaningful and something that
might help people
and so i started thinking about all the
songs that mean so much to me
that have a story to tell and i just
thought this they lend themselves so
well to acoustic
and how cool would it be to do a full
acoustic record cause i found your
hoodie
and my backseat still smells like you
you first came to the forefront for a
lot of people back in the voice
congratulations you have just won
the voice looking back would you do
everything the exact same way
i would um i say that with a little bit
of
hesitancy because i'm a big believer and
everything happens for a reason and i'm
i love where i am in my life and i'm
proud of the things i've accomplished
but there are things that that i the
main thing that i wish i would have done
more of is trust myself
because a lot of times where i've either
i've loved a song that
um my team talked me out of cutting or i
felt really strongly about
not doing this tour or not putting out
this song and the team kind of
like talked me into doing it and i
regretted it things like that
where i just i wasn't confident and
secure enough to trust myself
but if i had been it wouldn't have led
me to hear so it's kind of a
kind of a conflicting feeling but you
don't get me
it's a way you gotta keep on holding me
back
like this was it recently was a long
time ago or was just an accumulation of
events that made you
finally say to yourself like i have to
take my fate into my own hands
um it was 2017. i remember
very vividly the year that i got off my
record label
my management publishing i got out of my
long-term relationship
that year and it was just a very
uncomfortable lonely confusing year
but it was also the year where i went to
therapy and i and i um
i read books on self discovery and self
help and self love and
what it really means to love yourself
and all that stuff
and ever since then it's just been
reward after reward and
i yeah i wish i had known about that
earlier and made that decision earlier
but
i wasn't ready for it back then